[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 27 janvier voici
les titres à presque 900 jours de paris
2024 c'est en ce moment la semaine
olympique et paralympique une sixième
édition portée par le comité
d'organisation et l'éducation nationale
autour cette année de l'environnement et
du climat à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
300 enfants découvrent les sites
olympiques de l'agglomération nous
étions hier au vélodrome nationale après
du vs cussac le laboratoire atmosphères
observations spatiales travaille sur un
nouveau nano satellites in spears at 7
sera mise en orbite en janvier 2023 il
réalisera des observations pendant au
moins deux ans de notre terre et de son
climat à 500 km d'altitude
enfin l'espace rambouillet reste fermé
cette année une situation qui se
poursuivra jusqu'à la rentrée avec la
reprise du parc animalier par un
gestionnaire privé que se passe-t-il sur
place en attendant le retour des
visiteurs reportage
mais avant de développer ces titres la
suite de cette polémique à trappes qui a
secoué l éducation nationale fin 2021
une enseignante de trappes avait été
menacée est accusé de racisme après
avoir utilisé une faute heures d'une
photo du rappeur soprano lors d'un cours
sur l'évolution de l'espèce humaine une
photo avait été postée ensuite sur
facebook par un père de l'une des ses de
ses élèves s'en est suivi un mouvement
de menaces de mort à l'encontre de la
professeur qui a porté plainte elle a dû
être exfiltré vers une autre académie
son avocat a été reçu vendredi par les
représentants du rectorat de versailles
et le président académique du syndicat
national des lycées et collèges propos
recueillis par justine brasier nous
avons pu échanger effectivement sur la
situation de ma clients mais également
sur le déroulement de cette triste
affaire et
nous sommes tous ressortis avec cette
idée qu'il fallait savoir en tirer les
leçons l'avenir administratif de ma
cliente s'est éclairci
donc on a eu des avancées majeures avec
le temps le rectorat de versailles que
le ministère de l'éducation nationale et
donc je me réjouis comme un client de
d'ailleurs qu'elle bénéficie désormais
d'une affectation
définitive pour la rentrée prochaine le
1er septembre 2022 qui soit une
affectation conforme à ses voeux écoutez
à présent la réaction du snalc le
syndicat national des lycées et collèges
dans cette interview express collectées
par célia tsonga
[Musique]
nous avons pensé
que la situation était très grave
et qu'elle n'est pas prise au sérieux et
que alors quand même il y avait ainsi
très grave qui était la sphère pâtit et
qu'on n'en tirait pas les leçons ce que
nous dénonçons aussi c'est l'attitude de
l'adjoint du chef d'établissement qui a
osé
critiqué l'octroi de la protection
fonctionnelle en disant que pour el
salam sall a choqué et qu'elle appuie la
position qui n'est pas axa je dénoncerai
l'attitude de l'administration pas
clairement et nous demandons que la des
sanctions
la collègue a été dans un premier temps
elle était en arrêt maladie
ensuite on a rencontré l'avocat on a
fait le point on est intervenu plusieurs
fois y compris en vision parce que c'est
compliqué le colis pour que la collègue
rejoignent plus l'établissement à la
rentrée de la terre parce qu'elle a
passé l'année scolaire ailleurs à
collègues du
demandions que les choses soient faites
lalanne arrêté qui la nomme sur
l'académie où là elle est près de sa
famille et sécurisé
notre action c'est de défendre les
collègues qui sont systématiquement
maintenant on va placer en placer en
position d'appui et de réclamer de
l'administration elles défendent des
collèges et qu'elle organise ces
rencontres justement très pratique très
fausse un prêt faisable dans lesquelles
on peut voir
les problèmes actuellement et échanger
discuter
[Musique]
je vous le disais dans les titres la
sixième édition de la semaine olympique
et paralympique se déroule jusqu'au 29
janvier de nombreux ateliers sportifs
sont organisés à saint quentin en
yvelines le but c'est de faire découvrir
les trois sites olympiques présents dans
l'agglomération le golf national la
colline d'elancourt et le vélodrome
nationale où nous étions ce mercredi à
le reportage de justin brasier de julien
leroy ils étaient une vingtaine d'élèves
saint quentinois s'initier au bmx ce
mercredi 26 janvier des ateliers ont
pris place au stadium olympique de bmx
implanté au vélodrome nationale à
montigny le bretonneux
les athlètes en herbe ont pu découvrir
cette discipline olympique c'est une
activité qui est peu connu mais qu'on a
la chance d'avoir vraiment à proximité
sur notre territoire c'est une activité
nouvelle à sensations fortes que les
élèves aiment beaucoup donc c'est génial
pour eux de pouvoir l'expérimenté
aujourd'hui des ateliers qui
s'inscrivent dans le cadre de la semaine
olympique et paralympique
objectif faire découvrir aux élèves de
saint quentin en yvelines et les sites
olympiques l'initiation s'est déroulée
en trois temps qu'à une partie prise en
main sur le plat avec des petits
exercices d'équilibré ensuite on fait
une partie sur une petite ligne
pumptrack pour qu'ils apprennent à
passer les bosses et en troisième partie
de séance donc sur la fin de l'heure ils
vont sur la piste la vraie piste bmx
donc on commence par les bosses sur la
dernière ligne droite parce que c'est
les plus petites bosses de la pisse
ensuite en général on fait troisième et
quatrième lignes et on finit par un tour
complet de piste des ateliers encadrés
par romain racines l'athlète est arrivé
deuxième en dernière coupe du monde de
bmx en élite c'est un plaisir de pouvoir
partager mon expérience avec eux et
également avec les jeunes de la hesse
qui encadrent eux aussi et du coup on
fait notre cd jeunes qu'on encadre enfin
moi même que j'encadre au cours de
l'année du coup ça me permet de tout
simplement pouvoir encadrer les sessions
avec eux et de leur montrer comment
cadrer aussi un au public prochain
événement vendredi 28 janvier au
programme une randonnée pour découvrir
la colline d'elancourt on continue à
parler de cette semaine olympique avec
mon invité par visioconférence maxime
lucas bonsoir enfin vous êtes chargé de
promotion golf et vie sportive à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines il s'agit donc de la sixième
édition de cette semaine olympique et
paralympique qui a démarré à saint
quentin en yvelines au golf national
elle est passée donc par le vélodrome
nationale elle va se terminer demain
vendredi sur la colline d'elancourt on
va en parler cet événement est porté par
le comité d'organisation de paris 2024
et l'éducation nationale quels sont les
objectifs
alors l'objectif annoncé est
voulue par paris 2024 et l'éducation
nationale c'est de mettre plus de sport
dans le quotidien des écoliers donc la
semaine olympique c'est une action qui
s'adresse à l'ensemble des écoliers que
sa part de la primaire jusqu'au lycée
est donc l'objectif voilà c'est de
mettre plus de sport dans le quotidien
de cette génération de 1024 puisque les
enfants auraient perdu en moyenne en
plus un quart de leurs capacités
physiques avec les différents
confinement comprend aussi un truc
l'importance du sport en matière voilà
pour éviter l'obésité les maladies
cardiovasculaires ou également le
diabète l'idée aussi maxime lucas c'est
de préparer cette génération de 1024 600
quelque sorte cette génération qui va
faire vivre ces jo celle ci qui va
emporter l'héritage ensuite oui tout à
fait sur saint quentin en yvelines mais
les enfants à qui en adresse ces actions
cédées et des enfants qui vont avoir la
chance de pouvoir vivre plusieurs
disciplines sur leur territoire on a de
la chance on a un territoire qui est
composé de quatre sites olympiques et y
aura cinq épreuves qui vont se déroule à
saint quentin en yvelines donc il est
très important pour nous de faire la
promotion de ces jeux olympiques et
paralympiques auprès de ces scolaires et
le thème cette année c'est
l'environnement et le climat sain
s'inscrit pleinement dans l'objectif de
paris 2024 d'être djo durable comment
vous vous êtes adapté justement à cette
thématique en proposant des animations
quel type d'animation vous avez proposé
alors sur les actions qu'on a mise en
place on a on a essayé de coller à la
thématique de paris 2004 alors au golf
national on a mis en place une visite de
golf qui étaient encadrés par le
responsable environnement du golf
national donc les enfants pourraient
parcourir le golfe et observer la
biodiversité qui est présente pendant
une heure et il y avait toute une
stabilité autour de la permaculture
les personnels du golf national est en
train de réaliser des tests sur un
potager en permaculture à partir des
déchets verts du golf national et donc
ce cette étude sur la permaculture elle
vise à terme de réaliser des sols de des
sols sportifs en permaculture donc avec
moins de moins d'eau moins de produits
phytosanitaires et surtout la
valorisation des déchets
sur le vélodrome on était avec une
entreprise qui est partenaire du
vélodrome et qui réutilise des déchets
de pneus et de chambre à air pour faire
des des différents objets des porte-clés
des portefeuilles des flaques ado est
donc là aussi on est sur la valorisation
des déchets la réduction des déchets et
du coup de main sur la colline
d'elancourt il ya toute une
sensibilisation autour des déchets aussi
avec la gaillette vie des déchets et
donc pour sensibiliser ses enfants au
fait de ne pas de pas jeter ses déchets
dans la nature donc il va se terminer on
le disait cette semaine olympique demain
vous le disiez demain vendredi sur ce
site de la colline d'elancourt
vingt-et-une classe 300 élèves venus des
dix de dix des douze communes de
l'agglomération elles ont été
sélectionnées commencé classe alors il
ya un peu plus d'élèves on sera autour
de 600 élèves
d'accord alors mais on est bon sur le
nombre de classes y en aura bien
vingt-et-une qu'on aura tous recevoir ça
va deux de la primaire jusqu'au lycée
donc le premier critère qui a été mis en
place sur la sélection de ces classes
c'est essayer d'avoir le maximum de
communes représentées donc on peut avoir
on a dix communes de l'agglomération qui
sont représentés et ensuite on a
favorisé les les classer les
établissements qui sont labellisés
génération 2024 donc le label génération
de 1024 c'est un label qui est mis en
place par l'éducation nationale et paris
2024 pour viser à mettre en place à
mettre en route une dynamique au sein
des établissements sur sur la thématique
des jeux olympiques et vous vous êtes
aussi appuyé sur les partenaires c'est
ça pour organiser cette semaine on a vu
des reportages précédents notamment
l'urss ouais alors c'est une semaine qui
est qu'organiser un nous on est un
acteur non n'est pas le seul la seule
partie prenante sur cette semaine il yal
unss départementale l unss au niveau de
l'académie de versailles aussi qui est
mobilisé et lucette
lucette 78 et on a aussi été très bien
accueilli que ce soit au golf national
et au vélodrome nationale qui ont tout
fait et tout mis en oeuvre pour pour
mettre en place ces actions et avoir un
programme de qualité on imagine que ces
semaines vont se poursuivre jusqu'en
2024 et encore deux éditions de la
semaine olympique et paralympique c'est
bien ça c'est ça en 2000 la cette
édition 2022 c'est là c'est la seconde
pour laquelle saint quentin en yvelines
et acteur l'idée c'est de présenter un
programme de plus en plus dense jusqu'en
2024 et après un parce qu'il ya
l'héritage des jo qui est important
là on a
on a tous limités dans notre
programmation pour s'adapter aux
contraintes sanitaires mais mais l'idée
voilà c'est vraiment densifier c'est
cette action de semaine olympique et
puis la diversifier il ya plein d'autres
actions qui vont être mises en place
vers le public scolaire
la journée olympique c'est ça qui avait
été proposé l'année dernière sur le le
site du golf national ou est ce que ce
sera cette année sa base super là cette
année il ya également la journée
olympique la journée olympique c'est le
23 juin ça ne change pas d'une année sur
l'autre et donc l'idée on a 50 ans en
yvelines c'est de partir de cette
journée olympique pour faire découvrir
là aussi les sites olympiques
l'année dernière on était au golf
national et cette année on sera sur le
vélodrome nationale et sur l'île de
loisirs donc l'idée c'est d'accueillir
le maximum de deux classes et d'élèves
l'année dernière on était autour de 500
élèves la sai on souhaite encore
augmenté on a une une vingtaine de
partenaires comité ligues clubs du
territoire fédération
voilà c'est de multiplier encore ses
partenaires pour proposer le maximum de
disciplines aux élèves qu'on pourra
accueillir le 23 jan donc ce sera le 23
juin vous l'avais dit au vélodrome
nationale et la semaine olympique et
paralympique elle se poursuit au niveau
national jusqu'au 29 janvier et demain
dernier rendez vous sur la colline des
longs cours merci maxime lucas d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous je rappelle
chargée de promotion golf et vie
sportive à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également la visite
ministérielle ce matin dans les yvelines
ce jeudi matin à nadia s est rendu à
carrières sous poissy la ministre
déléguée chargée de la ville est venu
accordés à la commune le label de sites
et de la jeunesse distinction plus
précisément pour sa maison de la
jeunesse et de la réussite situé rue de
la reine blanche cité de la jeunesse a
pour objectif de valoriser et donner
plus de moyens aux structures locales
innovantes sur l'accompagnement social
des jeunes et pour leur émancipation
dans tous les domaines que ce soit pour
le sport la culture l'emploi la
citoyenneté les structures labellisées
obtiennent en moyenne une subvention
pouvant aller jusqu'à 70 mille euros les
nano satellites de l'observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines ont
la cote en ce moment alors que lui vs
cussac fournit tout moore et des données
quotidiennes concluante sur le climat un
nouvel appareil baptisé in spears at 7
est en cours de préparation il rejoindra
dans un an son grand frère pour former
la première constellation de cube stade
dans l'espace dédié à l'étude du climat
et de la terre les précisions de céline
chardin
souvenez vous il y a tout juste un an le
premier nano satellites d'étude du
climat et est envoyé dans l'espace par
le laboratoire atmosphères observations
spatiales de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
premier satellite qui fournit des
données scientifiques exploitables il va
être rejoint par son petit frère inspire
7,7 dans l'objectif final de créer une
constellation de petits satellites nous
avons mis en oeuvre un deuxième
satellite qui s'appelle inspire sats est
donc son objectif c'est de faire une
étude
du bilan radiatif de la terre donc on va
s'intéresser à l'étude du climat et on
cherche à mesurer des variables
climatiques essentielles le premier
démontre qu'un anneau sat est capable de
donner des données scientifiques utile
mais l'idée c'était de quand même de
voir si une constellation de plusieurs
satellites rajoute pas une plus value
importante en faisant des tendres visite
au dessus d'un même point plus rapide
véritable bijou de technologie il pèse
seulement 3 kg et fait la taille de de
rubik's cube reste dans le standard
cubesat c'est à dire c'est des carrés de
10 par dix mais là on a rassemblé 2
carré de 10 par dix vous avez des
cellules solaires sur chaque face
cave cellules solaires ça ça va nous
permettre de générer une puissance
d'environ une dizaine de watts par face
ensuite sur ses droits nous avons des
hommes blanchis sur lesquels vous en
venir fixer nos capteurs nous utilisons
des détecteurs plans pour pouvoir faire
des mesures de flux infrarouge pour
faire nos mesures de déséquilibre
énergétique toute la phase de conception
et de réflexion sur la science a été
fait maintenant on en est à l'assemblage
donc on va voir si moi d'assemblage de
tests avec les outils que l'on a ici à
guyancourt qui permet vraiment de tester
si clash thermique le vide tout tout ce
qui est nécessaire et puis après il ya
tous les étalonnages pour pouvoir
effectivement livre est l'instrument à
temps pour qu'ils embarquent tous les
essais sont effectués sur place au total
c'est une équipe d'une dizaine de
chercheurs qui s'ils occupent
quotidiennement le lancement d'un spears
at 7 est prévue en début 2023
l'université versailles saint quentin
qui débute à partir de samedi un cycle
de portes ouvertes en pleine période de
saisie des voeux sur parcours sub ce
samedi l'iut de vélizy villacoublay
l'institut des sciences et technique de
vélizy vous accueillerons de 10h à 17h
l'occasion de rencontrer et d'échanger
avec des professeurs étudiants ou
experts de l'orientation de nouvelles
dates sur d'autres campus de l'ue vs qu
seront proposés début février et des
stands en ligne sont également
accessibles depuis le 24 janvier sur le
site de l'ue vs qu avec plaquettes vidéo
et même accès à des conférences en
direct
direction à présent la forêt plus
précisément entre mario roy et
saint-germain-en-laye la pépinière les
serres des princesses propose à la vente
une grande diversité de produits elle
est associée à l'entreprise et d'un
pépiniériste engagé passionné mais aussi
au lycée agricole de saint germain en
laye ces partenariats permettent aussi
de promouvoir la transmission des savoir
faire le reportage de céline charles
tellier gars de sangomar cogestion
entourée de forêts en plein coeur des
yvelines la pépinière les serres des
princesses à saint germain en laye a en
apparence tout une pépinière classique
on peut y acheter des fleurs des arbres
des légumes et des conserves mais c'est
pourtant la seule ville de france à
avoir quatre pôles de production le
verger le maraîchage la floriculture et
la pépinière on a des méthodes de
gestion qui sont un petit peu qui veut
pas conventionnel on va dire et qui
s'intègre dans don dans l'actualité
c'est à dire l'intégration de la
biodiversité dans nos pratiques la
pépinière plus axé sur la production
travaille en étroite collaboration avec
la société halte et corporacion géré par
adrien le tallec plus spécialisés sur la
commercialisation un partenariat gagnant
gagnant qui permet à adrien le tallec
d'accueillir au sein de la pépinière des
élèves en stage ou en formation des
personnes en reconversion ou encore des
travailleurs handicapés ce qu'on va
mettre en avant
avant tout c'est la formation ces deux
de pouvoir
valoriser le métier et donner envie aux
jeunes et aux moins jeunes de découvrir
le métier alors lui si on va reprendre
le chiffrage sur lequel on était on peut
aller sur du ceap et du bac trop
donc plus des postes d'ouvriers
jusqu'à ensuite des formations plus
diplômante plus certifiante comme lucie
où là on est sur une formation assistant
métreur moment j'étais dans la
conception j'ai fait une formation
collaborateurs concepteur paysagiste
dans l'établissement cfa et du coup là
de mon intérêt c'était de voir le
chiffrage est vraiment le mettrais et le
terrain comme je n'ai pas encore fait de
terrain jusque là également associé au
lycée horticole et agricole de saint
germain en laye la pépinière s'articule
autour de deux maîtres mots production
et pédagogie elle accueille des élèves
du lycée en formation durant leurs cours
pratiques le but est de leur faire
acquérir des compétences et des
capacités pour qu'ils puissent gérer par
eux-mêmes leurs chantiers et que ça
puisse leur servir dans leur vie
professionnelle future j'ai entraîné
faire un rempotage et un rempotage c'est
remettre de la plainte dans une nouvelle
pop j'ai beaucoup appris et dont il est
quatre domaines parce que ici ils font
qu'ils les quatre domaines des valeurs
de transmission qui sont chers à la
pépinière comme adrien le tallec et qui
permettent chaque année à des dizaines
d'élèves de trouver leur vocation
nous vous l'avions annoncé en octobre
dernier l'espace rambouillet va être
repris par un gestionnaire privé comment
le parc animalier est il géré pendant
cette longue fermeture c'est ce que
justin brasier est allé constater sur
place cette année pas de visites guidées
prévu pour l'espace rambouillet le parc
restera exceptionnellement fermée pour
cause sa reprise par un gestionnaire
privé à la rentrée pour la dizaine de
salariés le temps passe et d'ordinaire
avec les visiteurs seraient occupés
cette année par l'entretien des lieux et
le bien-être des animaux
[Musique]
l'objectif c'est de s'occuper des
animaux et du bien-être des animaux dont
les alimenter sur le beau métal la forêt
de voir
des clôtures parce que ça parte au clos
donc il faut s'assurer qu'ils aient pas
de trou dans le grillage
si c'est le cas il faut réparer l'espace
rambouillet regorge d'espèces 4 en forêt
sauvage avec les daims les sangliers les
chevreuils et les serres mais aussi une
quarantaine d'espèces de rapaces des
oiseaux qui chaque année volts en
présentation devant un public malgré la
fermeture pas question de les priver
d'exercice
[Musique]
on va ressortir de volières on va les
remettre en condition de voir qu'on va
les faire voler là ce sera pour nous
quand on entre nous l'arrêt pas de
visiteurs donc on prendra le temps de
faire les choses bien laisser voler à
leur aise l'espace rambouillet accueille
également un centre de soins de la faune
sauvage toute l'année les particuliers
peuvent y déposer les oiseaux trouvé en
détresse 250 oiseaux ont été reçus en
2021 objectif les soigner et les
relâcher la vétérinaire qui vient
plusieurs fois par semaine qui fait
partie de l'équipe
c qui est responsable de centre de soins
donc là c'est une petite buse variable
qui a été trouvé sur l'autoroute
en particulier
elle donc là certainement du choc avec
un
emploi
retrouvez été un peu affaibli donc
l'objectif c'est la remette en
lagrasse wii est la cession du parc
animalier devrait se faire à l'été 2022
c'est une qualité de vie courante c'est
important c'est pour ça qu'il faut
préserver ce parc là j'espère qu'il va
être offrir à quelqu'un de bien la
reprise avec le nouveau concessionnaire
devrait avoir lieu en septembre
et puis une boulangerie du sud-yvelines
distinguer les blés d'or et lauréat de
la meilleure galette aux amandes thomas
gourland président de rambouillet
territoire et anne cabri présidente et
du parc naturel régional de la haute
vallée de chevreuse sont venus féliciter
ce mercredi guy bernier le propriétaire
de boulangers ont été primés théo
rafesthain vatan 20 ans qui a remporté
le premier prix catégorie salariés sarah
gendry 17 ans deuxième dans la catégorie
apprentis la meilleure galette aux
amandes est un concours organisé par la
fédération de la boulangerie pâtisserie
de l'essonne du val d'oise et des
yvelines bravo aux deux primés c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité
demain vendredi place aux 7,8 week-end
de l'actualité des idées de sorties pour
bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines quand au journal retour lundi à
partir de 18h en direct belle soirée sur
tb 78
[Musique]